vous vous n'avez joué pour ce suicide le
malaise dans la police
ils touchent toute la profession depuis
des décennies au quotidien les agents
sont confrontés à la misère et à la
violence de la société avec des moyens
insuffisants
ce ras-le-bol ils l'expriment depuis les
années 70 pour les régions tiennent
essentiellement aux moyens et aux
conditions de travail
il ya à peu près un véhicule pour 15
nous n'avons pas de matériel radio les
inspecteurs de police dispose à peu près
d'une machine à écrire pour voir le même
sentiment s'exprime en 1981 il fallait
se colle à risque on peut manière un
illuminateur commun c'est l'argent et
l'argent liquide mais ce n'est pas grand
chose comparé à 1996 une année noire
dans la police française 70 suicides
d'agents sont recensés un mort tous les
cinq jours
et si à la seconde
peck et plus on alarme oeuvre chez soi
comme tout le monde les collègues n'ont
donc fait 90% de chances qu'on prenne la
main pour au manque de moyens s'ajoute
le stress et les heures interminables
durant cette année 96
la france est en plan vigipirate après
une vague d'attentats
la police est à bout les autorités ne
peuvent plus le billet nous voulions
voir comment faire en sorte d'éviter ces
drames si c'est possible
la solution du ministre de l'intérieur
celle écoute
cette même année 96 il met très vite en
place le service de soutien
psychologique opérationnel qui existe
encore aujourd'hui
les policiers ont besoin de parler de ce
qu'ils ont vécu des émotions qui n'était
mise en oeuvre pour pouvoir les gérer à
titre préventif et pour rester
opérationnels nouveau coup dur pour les
forces de l'ordre en 2015
attentat de charlie hebdo ce du 13
novembre et l'état d'urgence
les agents ont été très sollicités au
point d'annuler des congés et des
formations
à partir du moment où vous ne cessez
bien d'accumuler les missions ou qu'elle
dure de plus en plus longtemps et bien
physiologiquement les policiers ne sont
pas des robots 2019 et la mobilisation
des gilets jaunes ont réveillé le
douloureux souvenir de 1996 et sa vague
de suicides
il y en a eu 59 en 2019 aujourd'hui les
agents demandent plus de moyens dans un
contexte de défiance d'une partie de la
population et d'accusations de violences
policières médiatisé
[Musique]